the State of Israel was founded on May
15 1948 on much of the land that was
known as Palestine so what happened to
the Palestinians well about 80% of them
became refugees fleeing to the West Bank
Gaza and surrounding countries the rest
stayed behind where they lived under
military rule without rights until they
were given Israeli citizenship in 1967
that year Israel occupied the rest of
historic Palestine during the six-day
war taking over the West Bank in Gaza
from Jordan in Egypt today there are
around 12 million Palestinians worldwide
about a million of them have Israeli
passports but they complain of being
treated like second-class citizens
close to 5 million live under occupation
or siege in the West Bank in Gaza where
they have no political representation
and the rest are spread around the world
many cylinder Fuji camps having never
been allowed to return that's why while
Israelis celebrate May 15th as their
Independence Day Palestinians call it
the neck but the Arabic word for
catastrophe